i think he'll be quite direct and he
starts with e4 the kingsport opening and
okay the sicilian defense from magnus we
never saw this in the world championship
match magnus playing the sicilian every
time there he just played solid by
replying with the black king's pawn so
now we will see surely some world
championship preparation on the show
look at the pontiac he was just looking
off to the side there now looking down
sipping his tee he's just trying to
remember what he had planned for the
world championship match in this opening
this is something magnus rarely actually
employs these days pushing this pawn uh
usually we see him do something else but
uh yeah of course magnus has been here
before yan have has also been here
before and okay jumping into the center
with the black knight
it's actually funny because magnus's
first three moves in this game
are the same three moves that he played
with white in the last game he played
the same exactly the same setup with the
white pieces so uh he often does this so
he he goes to similar uh kind of
positions but moving the knight in there
is is the first kind of unique idea i
guess david okay and what's he having
for his dinner there magnus it looks
like some kind of takeaway
is it noodles i don't think it's noodles
but it does look like maybe some kind of
asian cuisine
meanwhile a trade of knights in the
centre of the board and white's bishop
getting kicked back
um this is still relatively well known i
think black's bishop coming out
and this pawn push gaining time against
the black bishop black is struggling for
development as simon mentioned it's a
bit of a mirror image almost of the last
game between these two um magnus with
white was struggling to get his pieces
out now with black as well still a
couple of moves away from castling his
king
to me this feels like a strategy that
might backfire napoli actually will see
the enemy king in the middle of the
board and he'll try and go for it if he
can
this says this still
is such a cool image to me these two top
sportsmen top chess players in the world
sitting here fighting in a big final
with the you know twenty five thousand
dollars for the winner it's a trophy
and they're eating takeaway it's just
you never you don't see that in any
other sport i think it must be uh some
sort of other esport
actually it'll be interesting and for
followers out there of other esports
does this happen regularly do they just
whip out some noodles halfway through
the game
i guess you can't i guess you're so
occupied with the mouse i guess the
mouse and whatever isn't that play with
he's diving in there yeah yeah he's deep
diving into his into his noodles and uh
something with rice it looks like yeah
he's getting free he's getting shoveling
it in there
needs the energy
this is where chess players differ
because i mentioned yesterday on the
show i hate playing
when i've got a full belly i just can't
focus i feel a bit lethargic a bit tired
but bloated but magnus he we've seen it
he loves eating during the games plus it
must be so nice to celebrate with a nice
meal after you played exactly gives you
something to look forward to yeah
but uh no magnus we saw actually on last
season uh of the mount water
championship tour his eating habits they
did distract him slightly often blunders
came immediately after he'd started
eating he just takes his eye off the
ball for one second because it was it
would happen about 15 minutes or so
after he'd eaten like maybe they kind of
got that sugar rush and then it kind of
crashed um
talking about deep diving into the
position um mag niapomnierci's move
where he developed the knight to the
side of the board that was new i mean
this is kind of a little bit of a rare
line
but that was new and uh now the players
are completely in new territory and uh
napoleon's plan is clear you know he
just wants to put pressure
on that pawn sitting in the central
square and he wants magnus to take a
decision to kind of exchange the pawns
preferably yeah let's jump in just to
show what is happening it's all about
this foreigner mentioned black wants to
keep it there as long as possible
because it actually blocks up white's
position it's in white's half it's very
strong it
controls a lot of space but there's
pressure on it white's pawn threatens to
take it and the white knight also
threatens to take it so two decisions
here that magnus could really go for he
could capture a set of pawns and trade
but now white's bishop gets open and
gets access to a nice diagonal just
frees up the white position so this will
be a last resort for magnus or okay he
does play it i was going to say he could
back it up with his knight just to
defend this pawn but there will be some
consequences there too maybe some
downsides so
magnus deciding okay keeping things
simple is the best option for now and
after this trade instead of castling
which he needs to do very soon he brings
his queen out attacking this pawn and
maybe just stopping the white bishop
from using a diagonal it wanted to use
the white bishop wanted to develop to
this square now no longer possible
because of the black queen also some
hinting uh hinting of an idea of
checkmate later in the game maybe we'll
see this one and the black queen and
bishop teaming up towards the white king
and uh
david i just wanted to put a question to
you and there we see white push up his
pawn because i have a question from
siddhant puma who asks why aren't there
any more chess 960 world championships
if there was one would you play oh sedan
i would love to play i love chess 960.
actually earlier in 2021 i think for six
months i played a lot of online chess
but i never played
the chess as we know it uh i only played
chess 960 and a variant called king of
the hill so uh chess 960 it just teaches
you a lot about pawn structures where to
put pieces it's all about understanding
rather than memorization uh with the
opening so yeah i would love to play i'm
not sure i could compete with these guys
um and wesley so of course the current
chess 960 world champion but i hope
there's another championship at some
point i think there's a world
championships in iceland isn't there at
the end of this year okay yeah i think
so right so october november time 9 60.
yeah 2016. okay
because it was in norway before was it
it was in norway and um
yeah i loved 960 as well i mean i think
trying out these these different games
is uh actually quite good for your chest
so i play this one called free check
where you have to get free checks in a
row and it teaches you you have to just
attack basically so it's nice to have a
little change down again and the good
thing about 960 is you you don't have to
learn the openings so yes it's great but
i've never worked out how to castle with
960. i'm still i'm still struggling with
that rule it's very strange it's easy
simon you just you end up with your king
and rook on the same square as you would
in normal chess yeah still can't do it
but you have to move maybe a lot more
pieces of course depending on where on
the board the the king yeah sometimes
your king actually travels five or six
squares rather than just uh in standard
chess the king starts in the middle and
it goes either two squares to the right
or two squares to the left in chess
um some you need nothing in between your
king and rook but sometimes your king
goes six squares across the board
and often it's really really late in the
game when your opponent has forgotten
it's possible you can also castle and
move one i remember i had a position
where you know you can literally castle
on your first move and that was just
slide out this is too much
it's too much
but this is why the gram everyone like
turns up early
when the round is announced it's
fantastic you know normally everyone's
late but this time like five minutes
before they're like yep you've got your
pairings here's the board here's the
yeah
everyone is running
their balls
what can i play
you can check mate in like two moves as
well
i think magnus once lost a game in what
was it three or four moves wow
just because he'd forgotten that one of
the opponent's pieces was attacking
something and
and oh maybe it was when he just forgot
his opponent could castle actually and
he lost a piece or rook just with one
move um it's so tricky chess 960 to even
survive past the first few moves and uh
definitely i think one of the variants
of chess which will teach you actually
the most about general chess
understanding lots of crossover there
meanwhile if we catch up with the game
not too much has changed we saw the dark
squared bishops get traded and now a set
of pawns have left the board as well so
black has this open file with his rook
on the a line
and uh it's quite similar to the first
game david i think isn't it as in
the pawn structure magnus again has that
extra pawn in the center of the board so
um you know typically if you can last a
bit longer that pawn could be very
useful uh in the ending it's a bit so
quite solid but white has maybe more
attacking chances here i mean i would
love to be pushing my f pawn forwards if
i was white and trying to storm the
black king and
we talked about how uh jan should win
this match and we said his best chance
is probably by attacking so i really
hope we see uh him just throwing that
pawn forwards and trying to get it all
the way up the board as far as it can go
maybe to open up the black king i mean
that's a very typical idea here if you
can play it but magnus has
obviously good development and a very
sound position so it's not going to be
easy to break through yeah this pawn
push would love to be played by white
but he maybe needs to just prepare it a
bit longer
first and uh yeah i mean for example if
he pushed it now a lot of weaknesses now
for white to defend as well so um that
would have been very very risky but
maybe desirable at some point in the
next few moves instead he just brings
his queen up
covering some squares the black rook
might want to use and uh
yeah it's unclear what exactly white's
aiming for maybe centralizing his fork
maybe pushing this pawn as you mentioned
meanwhile black is very flexible very
solid
i have a question for you both it was
always my understanding that these kind
of pawn structures with that big
pawn on the e4 square and the other pawn
on the c4 square
they're quite good
but when the light squared bishop is
trapped behind them and black gets a lot
of activity the position changes in
black's favor because of this bad bishop
now personally i would take black here
just because um white has pushed and
gained so much space but there are so
many holes behind these pawns and we all
have already seen a an exchange a trade
of two sets of minor pieces
if the bishops and knights which had
left the board if they were back on the
board i would take white every time just
because these pawns clamp down black is
struggling
all of the pieces want to occupy the
same squares but here it feels like
black is the one with more ideas i was
going to say black can jump in with the
queen to one of these squares he does
that he could also jump in with his
knight to one of these squares
black is very flexible with his rooks
that could infiltrate with his own rook
lots of ideas white maybe a bit more
stuck and after magnus did jump in with
the black queen
jan reacted instantly surprising because
he has options he brought his knight to
the side there's actually
the potential of a trap in this position
well i was wondering what happened if
white threw his knight into the middle
of the board and again this is following
the same pattern as the first game you
can remember in the first game that this
knight also jumped in so
can he can he even play it here possibly
yeah i mean it's a good question simon
try and liquidate some some bits off the
board yeah so this knight jumping in the
whole idea is that uh you are now
opening up this tension between the
queens if black's queen takes the white
queen then again another's visions are
not capturing the black queen instead
flicking in a check first knight takes
knight is a check the king will move now
you take the queen and this position
after black recaptures the knight it's
level pawns level material but i
slightly prefer black here just because
white's pawns are a bit weak and it got
to the ending and we said that black
wants to get to the ending in these kind
of positions actually that exchange is
probably just helped blackout get the
queens off the board better pawn
structure yeah also the question after
the knight jumps in is whether black can
capture with his own knight defending
the queen in the process and after the
knight is recaptured only now go for the
trade and again we end up in an endgame
it's not clear who's better here for
example it looks like black's about to
win a pawn but white could flick in
another check
and uh just showing off some tactics
here but a discovered attack against the
black bishop and
it will just fizzle out it would all
become level so in the current position
it doesn't look likely that jan would
try and copy the same strategy he used
last time but he does have to deal with
this pressure against this pawn now his
central pawn is under fire twice and
it's only defended once so jan needs to
defend this pawn and he needs to do it
quickly maybe with his own pawn but that
would be loose as well
i'm slightly surprised the evaluation is
in white's favor because black looks
completely fine here to me okay
he is up on the clock first game ended
in a draw this is game two and there is
a total of four rapid games today just
to decide the winner in the first match
uh they couldn't they can of course tie
the first match as well
uh and it's still possible also to end
it in three games first player to reach
two and a half points
will be the winner of the first match
but uh is this a game that can end up
with the winner is it too early to call
it's still early days all three results
definitely possible
i think jan would love to press and gain
some advantage i think this is a great
move that jan's played and this is why
maybe the computer likes white uh it's a
kind of a normal move but we talked
about white's pawns be weaknesses
black's got this horrible pawn on the
queen side um on the dark square and i
think white's just trying to aim to take
that pawn and uh this this uh i quite
like white's position actually um
it's a really clever move as you
mentioned uh let's explain the point
behind it because the bishop's dropped
back it looks like you're leaving a pawn
uh kind of blundering a pawn in a way
but now as you mentioned uh white has
ideas for example you could step up the
board with the queen actually this is a
pin now
hitting the black bishop and the queen
behind it but also
this pawn lonely and vulnerable it might
just drop off the board at some point i
don't think black can really go for this
because now it's actually also hard to
defend this bishop
so it feels like things would be turning
in white's favor here but if black
doesn't capture this pawn in the centre
of the board what else do you do after
the white's bishop retreats if black
just takes the time out for example
pushes a pawn creates some space for his
king and as simon mentions the queen can
come up target this guy you could also
think about maybe bringing the queen up
the hallway trading off i'm not sure
this might backfire but after a trade
here at least you have a strong square
for the rook you're still attacking this
pawn
and yeah maybe you're right simon uh
very clever move there from yandere
punichi these are the hardest moves to
see in chess sometimes just quiet
retreating moves especially when it
looks like your opponent has a threat
so yeah very nice move and black has to
be wary of this idea attacking the
isolated pawn
it just shows how fickle
we as the commentators can be because i
was like loving black's position and now
suddenly after this bishop retreat
yes simon good point i mean i would
still take black to be honest but
some immediate problems to solve maybe i
definitely take the white side at the
moment but i mean
i suppose we can get over this pawn then
then it's it's black he's got the the
pros but it can change quickly and in
chess gonna you miss one move and it can
be brutal when it happens you think
you're doing really well and you just
miss a very slight tactic and you're
suddenly losing uh but obviously it's
still still in the balance i'd say here
it seems seems pretty pretty even but
white white's got an idea how does black
stop this idea um so maybe at the moment
at least it's easier for yan uh to play
this position
um
so i i how how does he
how does he stop this bring his knight
to
to c6 stop the queen coming in maybe it
feels like at some point the black
knight has to mobilize it's not really
doing too much right now you would want
to normally bring it towards the king
side uh just as a defensive piece and
attacking piece okay magnus does just
push pawn um i actually show this on the
board but pushing harry two squares up i
think i'm affected by you simon i know i
was i was wondering what you're doing
there it's like you know he pushes it
one square instead and the evaluation
bar does react it goes off in white's
favor but uh yeah exactly it's like
almost it doesn't seem to stop white's
idea that's that's
just i mean you know the queen has two
very tempting squares to go into as
david pointed out now so uh and that is
the obvious one the other square was
also i feel quite quite you know quite
tempting yeah and uh magnus simply
retreating the queen so kind of
admitting that you know this queen foray
into the right side of the board didn't
work didn't work waste of time oh that's
a bad sign
but should white have put the queen
right into the middle i mean he's got it
in the middle square but i mean should
he have gone for the exchange of queens
which you generally don't want to do but
again as david pointed out this this
scraggling pawn of blacks on the queen
side is very weak i mean even here
you could play it in this position and
force the exchange of queens off um
i
i mean if it works it works that's the
thing it's one of those moves if it's
good it's going to be very very good
um
but black can always bring the knight
back i guess to defend but it's very
passive
okay now i i want it i wanted to play
this move but i thought it lost the pawn
because i want to open up my bishop and
go for checkmate
what
does it lose i know because the queen
steps back ah okay this is really really
aggressive by yanaponechi he clearly
wants to win this game yeah he's going
on the attack now even though there's
been some trades he's going for it
let's show what's happening let's keep
an eye on the players as well because we
might see some reactions and simon you
mentioned does it lose a pawn black's
knight now after this pawn push can just
jump to the side and attack the white
queen attack the pawn at the same time
but
i'm trying to work out exactly what's
happening here because you mentioned the
queen may be stepping away from the
attack maybe retreating for example
lining up with a bishop and
trying to get to the black king maybe he
still grabbed the pawn yeah i mean uh
but
it is dangerous i mean
it looks scary but is it actually scary
you know the white queen will jump in
with a check the king has to move i mean
here there's tactics all over the place
for example like knight could jump in
one way yeah or the other yeah that i
was thinking that one or the other one
as well the other one looks tempted they
both look very same idea yeah similar
ideas this is what yam wants so isn't it
he wants this kind of position he wants
to get the attack yeah and he's got to
go for it so just to explain why this
knight jump or the other knight jump is
attractive because you take away the
only escape square from the black king
and now if the pawn captures suddenly
the white rook will sidestep also
cutting off this entire line and if the
queen moves out the way this would be
checkmate so definitely some scary ideas
for magnus this is four or five moves
down the line but yeah like if suddenly
black is the one having to calculate
things that's why magnus is burning time
on the clock now
because he's about to come under a
serious attack
and after this pawn push as mentioned
this bishop opening up and also this
idea is still in the bank if
uh if jan wants to bail out at any time
still maybe with an advantage he can
bring his queen up and swap it off for
black's queen and also white white if
white gets another move you've got this
queen idea of penetrating into the
position of the queen but you can you
can bring other pieces of attack your
knight can swing over to the king side
and we've we know what other pieces can
come over this is one of the common
themes we've seen the rooks can also if
given time come across and attack so
there's many white pieces
which are sort of able to come towards
black's king and if you look at black's
pieces they're all on the queen side so
you have to be very careful as black
here because if you give a couple of
moves you're just going to get
checkmated and this is a common pattern
right this uh this pawn on the e5 square
we see in all sorts of openings it often
cuts the board in half so this pawn
alone prevents the black queen from kind
of sneaking over to protect her king and
it just cuts any potential pawn pushes
by black this pawn push this pawn push
they'll no longer be defensive resources
because this guy is so strong and magnus
i think he wants to play this move he
wants to go and attack the queen attack
the pawn but he's calculating right now
can he get away with it and he decides
no he hasn't played it wow he brings
this rook into the game but
it feels like he's going after a pawn
which isn't too relevant right now well
the other thing you could do here i mean
it's anti-positional but what if you
just push that pawn on then you're kind
of all in meaning that you give away a
tremendous square for black next to that
pawn so you're not supposed to give away
squares but you stop black's maneuver
and you just get ready to throw all of
your pieces towards black's king and
this is what nepo needs to do to beat
magnus he needs to go straight for the
king i i think some simple move like
this makes a lot of sense
and then you load up and fire with your
next couple of moves yeah very scary for
black and the evaluation buyer agrees
with best play white is doing great
yeah and just instinct-wise something
just feels wrong for black this rook not
coordinated with the rest of its army
only attacking a pawn the black king no
defenders around it
uh yeah it just looks like jan has
danger
this is really dangerous giving me kind
of memories of magnus's game against
essepenko you know first magnus wasted
time
and then magnus went on the offensive
with a rook somewhere and started
chasing pawns and then of course he got
into serious trouble
with his own king
gosh
yeah this is i have to be honest when
when we started the commentaries today
um i was like okay it's gonna be really
tough for yan today for all the
circumstances he's also playing magnus
carlsen and now i'm like this is what i
wanted to see come on he played a very
good first game interesting ideas and
he's going for it and he's put the
pressure right onto magnus we've got a
real match now all of a sudden and
i'm i'm
thinking you know jan is not going to
get a better chance than this
if he got these types of positions in
the world championship match i think he
might have won it yeah it's just he
wasn't able to get this type of
attacking position we never saw jan
really on the offensive going for the
opponent's king going for magnus's king
magnus just didn't let him but this
opening
um it looked quite innocuous it looked
very innocent not much happening but
yan's last three moves have opened up
this potential attack and now
i mean there's so many tempting options
as you mentioned simon that pawn push is
so attractive um at least dynamically
maybe position needs some drawbacks
white's knight could even yeah making a
route for the black immediately if you
wanted to go really all in you just
throw the knight in now and just go
right okay you have my pawn i'm going to
checkmate you and you you certainly
could think about playing this move uh
move the knight towards black's game
could you be also quite clinical as well
can you just kind of go hang on a second
my my position is overwhelmingly i don't
even need to do anything what's this a
blunder
i'm not sure about a blunder but a bit
of a strange one he brings his queen
across to attack the black knight so
white's queen on the diagonal hitting
the black knight but
the queen wanted to use a different path
into the position right
the white queen in the center of the
board looked great okay that being said
black now has only one move to keep the
balance
and actually give himself the advantage
and that is not obvious right bringing
the black king to defend the knight
right that is not wow at all is
incredible i guess white's idea is to
black he has this hook black has moved
to pawn in front of his king and when
you move the pawn in front of your king
it becomes a target and white has a
target that he can capture with his
knight the knight can come bang bang as
i'm sure david will show here and just
destroy black's king's side so this is
actually a very brutal uh plan that
white has so i i mean this move
it does look very scary for magnus but
he's only got one reply yeah now will he
you found it in the last game but this
moving your king here
really
i mean you don't normally move your king
exactly it looks bizarre in a way just
moving your king
kind of towards towards the danger zone
but that is the best move and the
computer says black has the advantage
and maybe that's just because white is
too slow now white's queen temporarily
on the side of the board and uh if no
sacrifices work if no breakthroughs work
towards the black king actually suddenly
this pawn is under fire and this pawn is
under fire you can't defend them both so
maybe that's why the computer says black
is plus one up because white will lose a
pawn in this uh in this manner i mean
this this still looks fascinating if you
go knight to g4 here and you just
sacrifice it next move i mean i'd still
be very scared if i was black in this
position even if the computer says that
black is doing well here i i mean it
looks it still looks terrifying to me
yeah so i guess after rook takes born
for example you sacrifice and
maybe take a photo i think you can take
the pawn yeah maybe just take in the
center here calm defense and rely on
counter attacks
always
he actually yeah always this is why he's
the world champion i guess i mean knight
g8 there yeah i was about to say okay
the white knight could creep into the
position and uh utilizing some pins here
i'm not sure this fully works though
after for example black pushes with his
oh but then now there's a check maybe it
works oh this is this is crazy
crazy stuff coming towards the black
king it's all about the black king
either white is going to deliver
checkmate or he'll just be a pawn down
yeah for nothing and i'm just looking
back as well and there's chances that um
in the current position if white does go
all out on the attack with his knight
for example going for this pawn then
after rook takes maybe we just eliminate
some attackers first maybe for example
we can take this bishop getting rid of
an attacking piece and then now we take
the knight and it looks super scary
still to be honest but at least the
knight can block any potential checks
yeah black does have some
counter-attacking ideas of his own to
take this pawn or maybe even to go for
checkmate himself
and uh scary does anything can happen
here yeah it's just any resources all
three results on the cards yeah so this
this is what we wanted though we wanted
a lot of action uh we wanted to see yan
going for it and he's going for it um i
think he should just play this and yeah
hope for the best right roll the dice i
mean he's a little bit up on the clock
as well he's got a bit of time to think
here maybe he doesn't have so much
choice as well because he's dropping a
pawn right he's going to lose a pawn um
he's two pawns on pre he can't go safe
now yeah and uh between those two pawns
you kind of want to hold on to the
central pawn because like david
mentioned
earlier he cuts the board in half and as
we saw black has a bit of a fine line to
walk yep so
yeah i mean maybe after you moved the
night you could even you don't have to
sacrifice straight away maybe you could
try to bring the rook down he's going
for it going for the attack
he's all in right
yeah if this was poker he would his
chips would all be in the middle yeah
and uh yeah it's all about this
sacrifice trying to open up i mean i was
also thinking sorry dave i was also
thinking that you could go rook d4 maybe
after the next move try to get one more
piece in before you before you uh go for
it this might be a little bit slow but
you know we're going to see it will he
capture
that pawn on that hook on h6 now will he
go for it okay so current position is
this one this is an idea simon mentioned
lifting the rook up trying to swing it
across towards the black king but the
critical move the acid test of
everything black is doing is to play
knight takes pawn and the reason this is
so tempting is because if the knight is
captured then this is a deadly check if
the king marches to the center then
there's going to be more deadly checks
and if the king goes to the side of the
board then suddenly look at this bishop
it's been doing nothing for the last few
moves but now it's going to pounce and
this is actually one checkmating pattern
to remember bishop he's played it wow
check and the king would move another
check and this would actually end cool
checkmate this pattern
the fishy
the bishop
wow it is completely crazy this position
now the knight cannot be touched it's
poisoned and look at this you know the
computer's suggesting moves again it
does suggest giving up the rook for this
bishop as we showed in that line the
bishop potentially strong but then again
black could go for queen takes pawn that
looks fine for black as well and the
other move would be very very sneaky the
third choice of the computer is to lift
the queen up the board one square and
threaten checkmate on this diagonal both
sides now going for the opponent's kings
this is just crazy let's ignore the
evaluation bar because
yeah it's just wild yeah let's enjoy the
fireworks that are about to happen wow
but uh what about the the clock for
magnus he is down by is it four minutes
on the clock how crucial is that in this
position uh it could be crucial and i
think that was one of the factors behind
yan gambling and going for this attack
maybe in the back of his mind he knows
it's not going to be successful if black
defends perfectly but how do you defend
a crazy position like this perfectly
with three minutes yeah maybe magnus can
do it i mean we've seen him play the
best moves several times already he's
gone he's played the best move
i mean how did you beat this guy if he
just plays the best move every time
he's world champion simon i know i know
there is a reason for these things and
uh i mean the way he lost to duboff uh
in one of the previous tours was the
same kind of way it was duboff playing
these kind of very aggressive maybe
unsound sacrifices but magnus couldn't
quite defend properly
in those ones but here this is a lovely
movie actually just just bringing a
piece over to attack the queen and
defend
and uh yeah this knight jump was not
possible on the last turn because
white's bishop was actually staring down
at this square it would have captured
off the black knight but now black's
gonna get exactly what i showed but with
an extra move so magnus improving on the
line i showed earlier no matter where
the white queen goes now the white queen
attacked by the black knight then black
will capture this white knight and a
quick material account shows that black
has a bishop and a knight for one of the
white rooks white has a pawn
if we do a quick count white does have a
pawn extra in return but that's not
really a factor right now it's not about
pawns it's about pieces
black's knight and black's bishop
should be more powerful than one of the
white rooks and black's king for now at
least safe in the center
yeah it's it's quite crazy
it's very easy isn't it with a valuation
bar to know what's going on but even
here
i would be like
i i wouldn't know what actual the
evaluation is in a real game because
it's just so unclear i i agree and i
think for napoli actually the pressing
issue is he has to cover those potential
weaknesses on those light squares
because uh you know magnus has a bishop
and a knight that's uh two extra that's
one extra attacker because white just
has a rook
so the thing that i'm kind of concerned
about is that uh
magnus could in the next move just
simply line his bishop and queen on the
same diagonal and that's a tricky
checkmating idea that's difficult to
handle and if
white is forced on the defensive then
the black knight will spring forward and
suddenly there's three pieces attacking
that one point
so i i would think about reinforcing
that defensive strategy and then think
about
in the future of maybe advancing my the
king side pawns for white yeah white
also has two pawns under fire right now
um the central pawn and the pawn on the
c file
can't defend the both there's no checks
black's knight is covering all the
checks black's knight really is uh
king's best friend in this position and
i'm struggling uh white would love to
push harry the h1 forward but just a bit
slow
it does take a few moves to get motoring
and yeah maybe for now for the first
time i start to agree with the
evaluation but that being said uh napoli
actually trying he's throwing all the
doesn't like going backwards does he he
likes going forwards and uh i mean why
not you've got to keep going once you do
an attack like this as soon as you start
defending it it normally goes horribly
wrong um that works on a very nice
square as well yeah and yeah it stops
two of the ideas we've mentioned
um yeah what do we think black should be
playing here because just to show after
this rook move black cannot capture this
pawn in the center because now there
would be a check and a double attack
when the king moves the knight drops off
although
actually this rook is hanging it's not
so clear it's in such a complicated
position
every position is every position is full
of poison
i was going to advocate for the second
option greed
so i was going to say also this rook
move stops the black queen lining up
against this pawn meanwhile we do see a
couple of moves queen takes pawn was
played and after whites were captured
attacking the black bishop the black
bishop now attacking the white rook and
white has to be a bit careful here this
theme has cropped up so many times in
this tournament the white king has no
breathing space so you have to be
careful later about lifting the white
rook off the first rank because later
there might be checkmating patterns
against the white king for now it should
be okay white's rook can move for
example you can just sidestep attacking
the black queen because this rook is
defended by white's queen but
still crazy position and uh
right now the black queen would move i
guess somewhere to the center of the
board and it's just attack followed by
counter-attack now hitting the white
rook hitting the pawn in the center
who's better i don't know the evaluation
bar thinks black but
it's all about who can handle the
complications better and i just want to
mention one thing because i see it on
the bottom of the screen tour badges is
a new thing this season you can collect
tour badges from every single of the
nine tournaments and if you use the code
tour badge
you can get a 50 discount on chess 24
premium and there is also a
leaderboard that you can play to
win these badges very cool all right but
who's going to win this game is is this
going to be a game with a winner
yes ah looking that way a draw i think
is by far the least likely result right
now
and uh what's yan thinking about he has
to move that rook yeah i mean they're
both they're both now under um shortly
going to be under four minutes each so
it's uh
it's heating up very quickly um i i feel
it's going to be magnus's turn to attack
soon you know he's been kind of uh
playing
i wouldn't say defensively but he's been
on the back foot and often
in these situations the tide will change
uh when you have the extra or the more
active material so um
can he
can he start attacking very shortly we
will yeah find out yeah i mean okay he
drops this brook back attacking the
black queen attacking the bishop behind
it black's queen has to move and protect
her bishop um yeah this game feels like
jan's been cycling so fast on his
bicycle for the whole game but it feels
like the momentum slowed he's gonna
stop pedaling and that might let magnus
overtake and as you mentioned go for the
attack i think this is something ivanka
said a few days ago it was the game
was it between
duda
where it was the same material balance
white in that situation had a bishop
knight and a queen and the opponent was
with the one with the rook and the queen
knight bishop combined for a deadly
attack oh yeah yeah so right now it's
looking definitely in magnus's favor but
white's rook on the first row once it
moves from the attack of black's bishop
black still has some work to do at least
to create some dire threats does that
white king need some some lift does he
need some air very urgently yes
and uh okay white's rook did move out of
the eyeline of the black bishop i think
if white gets an extra move we would see
harry the edge pawn just shuffle up one
or two squares just to let the white
king breathe the air quality around that
white king the co2 levels are too high
let's open that window yeah it's very
close to being just winning for black
here if you could threaten checkmate
your queen but it doesn't doesn't quite
work
in the position but you have got three
black pieces quite near to that king is
there any way we can get them working
there
possibly i would love to get the black
rook in at some point as well um
yeah it feels like white won't be able
to stir up any threats over the next
couple of moves the only issue is that
if the black knight ever moves there
will be some checks from the white queen
to the black king i must admit i'm a bit
surprised by magnus's play because i
kind of thought that he would be going
for that uh weak pawn in the middle of
the ward yeah grab that one
maybe maybe he can do it just maybe just
move the bishop move the bishop away
somewhere safe somewhere protected and
then just grab it grab it yeah if he
gets rid of that when he has done if he
gets rid of that pawn it does seem like
okay you know blacks
black's really going to be so
comfortable there um so
yeah exactly because then then the king
is safe everything is okay the the you
step the king forward and the rook can
suddenly transfer between both sides
yeah yeah love it there's no way for
white to defend the central pawn now
white central point drop off but you
know what you know what you're doing
desperate situations don't you there's
only one pawn you push in every
situation
in every
situation yet push that man up the board
cross your fingers
and just punt him yeah and he's going
he's off that's exactly what jan is
doing crossing his fingers now because
on material terms black is a head and
now this knight jumping away from any
attack you know how the black queen
covers the corner square
i mean you have to be so confident in
this position still i mean like you know
and
still some threats yeah potentially
white's rook trying to join the action
also acting as a defensive piece white
rook defending the white king from the
front uh no immediate threats but
that white rook if it comes up to the
seventh rank then the white queen might
threaten some checks
still yan fighting hard
this is uh yep still not easy for magnus
despite what the evaluation bar says
yeah i i have a suspicion that um
magnus's best approach is probably to be
patient
because white's pieces look very
impressive very scary but you can't
actually get that far i think they've
kind of reached their maximum there and
so i think
it takes some time out it's only got
under a minute now yeah i know it's not
easy you could be patient
so he's uh put his rook on a protected
square this is good good strategy
it doesn't like it surprisingly because
it looks very natural
black does have some idea as well of
bringing his rook down to the first rank
trading off a set of rooks trying to get
through to the white king
if you can swap pieces here then black
maybe
pretty happy just because he has a
material advantage
also black's king now does have an
escape square it can just shuffle off to
the side and run over to the left side
of the board at some point
that's a nice idea david not immediately
but at some point over the next few
moves yeah depending on what white does
and uh
yeah this one as that tweet says this
one heating up
very exciting game yeah really good game
this one and now deadly threat on the
board deadly threat bring the queen and
blocking the the black screen
route to the corner so he's running
that that didn't work
why doesn't it work um
rick takes bishop
too
what's happening
this one is super complicated right now
uh white has just taken a pawn and
black's king cannot run because now the
knight is under fire and actually
there's a seat down there's some huge
threats white's queen is trying to come
up to the top of the board and then the
black rook in the corner would be taken
you can check you can take
you can check take the knight you've got
the h pawn i think this has happened
before magnus even though the computer
says he's winning as soon as he gets bit
of pressure he he doesn't find the right
defense could is jan winning now i think
he might be winning also look at that
white h pawn harry might decide this
game it might become a queen doesn't
does that really surprise you ever since
simon that keeps happening it shouldn't
really surprise you but it doesn't look
that magnus is reacting to this it looks
like jan has been reacting to this
magnus making a move with uh
with 50 seconds left on the clock i
think he just panicked maybe because of
the clock situation he had to make a
hasty decision and it just wasn't the
right one i think maybe the black king
could have run in a different way and
now this check clears the path for that
yh pawn to continue marching up the
board wow still not easy despite
uh i mean things are switching and
changing and twists and turns um i think
one slip and it might go back in black's
favor so white has to be careful now but
harry does advancement
is now back to being equal again this is
this is like very human game you forget
about the valuation bar if you if you if
this game was played like 60 years ago
and written about in a book
then it would be like oh yeah this is
actually just a great game because
people don't know the evaluation because
it's like bang bang bang bang bang it's
like you know everything's going on all
the time you're talking about that you
know there's only one move and that's to
give a check
centralize that queen
that's one of the first moves you look
for but any check for example queen to
e5 here which the computer's just
bringing the queen back with the check
it's just going to get blocked by a
white pawn so it's easy to see the first
move but the follow-up is going to be
15 seconds to find it i'm not sure he's
going to play it because the follow-up
is okay he does that
this is crazy but it's all about the
follow-up right
this move is obvious the first one but
after the white pawn pushes maybe
attacking the black queen yeah what next
that is the big question yeah with 24
seconds left magnus calls niana
pomnyacci still has more than three
minutes and that must be crucial in this
position yeah well i'm surprised by the
problem actually thinking because he
cannot push the other pawn because that
would just be a terminal weaknesses on
the light square so he has to attack the
queen what's wrong with pushing the pawn
is there anything what would black play
that attacking the queen
yeah attacking the queen here yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
expecting white's f pawn to
push forward now two squares because
tempo is so important right so you've
got to you've got to uh meet an attack
with a counter attack in such sharp
positions we've seen some adventurous
kings is jan really contemplating
pushing the white king forward one
square
that just looks unnecessarily brave yeah
just push that pawn forward and the game
would go on
i don't really understand the thinking
here either
uh maybe jan trying to look ahead
through a formula for the king let's
push his king forward gone with the king
both sides playing with fire now both uh
both kings vulnerable 15 seconds for
magnus carson here and jan is just
threatening to queen the h pawn so
magnus needs to find some counter play
quickly
against that h-pawn five
he's got to find something or he's just
gonna lose
one okay with two seconds on the clock
down okay and that's a silent draw offer
from magnus because now he's trying to
get the black queen across to track the
white king from behind but if the white
king steps back we've seen that position
before okay jan does not want the draw
playing for the wins playing for the win
good man wow and the bar is definitely
live in this game yeah and that check
from the white queen was blocked by
black's knight i'm surprised by that one
black's knight pinning itself and now
the black knight cannot move on this
diagonal but then again white does have
to reply to some threats black's queen
wants to come the whole way across the
board with a check to the white king
that would be really scary also black's
pawn in the centre of the board can step
down attacking the white queen
whoa
what a move by jan
he blocks this check with his queen and
the white queen now forced to the side
of the board are things turning suddenly
white has to look at that white queen
what is she doing behind her king
she's
any results possible and it has been for
the last 40 moves or something it seems
it's been a
very very tense this one very intensely
with the time situation yan
doesn't have a great deal of time either
here you have to defend your pawn now
there's a huge threat black's queen
trying to go back on the diagonal and
take white's pawn take harry off the
board that would end the game so white
needs to defend that pawn how do you do
it you either have to move your rook or
you have to move your king and advance
the king
is he going to do that that looks like
he does
you can't look you can't
even the guy is just fearless in this
game you've got to give him so much both
of them both of them yeah but i mean yan
turning down these drawers and going for
it i mean
it's really impressive it's incredible
i've i've never seen anyone be as brave
what's going on here you block with a
queen now your queen comes into the game
if you get the queens off you're winning
i mean uh
i
is that you know yeah i mean maybe this
brave king who's gonna work
maybe it's just gonna work from you
makes great sense yeah it's options so
simon what about pushing the king even
further
i mean because the black knight is
pinned the black knight can't join in
any attack against the white king but i
love the idea of getting my white queen
to a more a more centralized square okay
and um and i just want to i just want to
queen my favorite pawn here yeah it's
all about harry will that pawn become a
queen now this is another check this
time on the diagonal diagonal queen
checks are always the most effective now
white has to choose a square for the his
king
which square is safe are you tempted to
run up the board super tempted
especially in light of what he's done
previously but now the king retreats and
black finally blocks this pin so black's
knight now is finally free to move the
white queen has to run away
and uh where's she going
queen trade would benefit white here for
sure he offers it going for the exchange
and it looks like jan is uh happy with
uh his position right now he is nodding
oh but the bar reacting again
i mean no
neither of these two players can relax
because there will be more twists and
turns ahead for sure it's so imbalanced
this one miles away from a drawer this
one should end with a decisive result
look at that white pawn one square away
from promoting now wow and that's why
magnus gives a check and now the big
question is does he have any follow
follow-throughs after the king steps
back
okay jack again well there was actually
only one queen uh queen h3
wow is it is is this uh
well is it is he going to go queen takes
brook and played two
queens black's queen under fire once she
moves white's pawn is about to promote
but she gives a check the white rook can
block magnus shaking his head
oh maybe he missed this last move if the
black queen had taken the white rook
white would have made a new queen two
queens against one
black knight and bishop not able to
fight
he's just got a retreat here move that
rook back
or do you block with the white queen
gain a bit of time on the clock repeat
the position
yeah anything could still happen this is
crazy yeah the only way to win though is
to move the rook back otherwise we're
just repeating the position i guess so
you have to if you want to try and win
and then i guess black and he has played
it i mean jan really wants to win this
this is the only way to stop the h pawn
as well and um
that knight is doing a good job though
now yeah at night it's ready to give
itself up if white makes a new queen now
there's nothing else for it that white
pawn is too strong so black's knight on
a suicide mission but it will
eliminate that white pawn wow
okay where was he harriet briefly
briefly
before she was eliminated and now it's
still a crazy position still all results
possible this is so reminiscent of their
game six from the world championship
match where white was better black was
better white was better and uh it's
still crazy anything could still happen
white's king though not too happy the
white rook also pinned well suddenly
black's pawns have become very strong
and in this situation um the black king
can hide behind those pawns i mean often
your pawns are like your personal
bodyguards that's why you castle you
have your pawns in front of your king
but in these strange situations as well
you use those pawns to block the files
and uh this this pin that david pointed
out the on the white rook if white can't
get that rook into the game
maybe i'm starting to uh take magnus's
side here you know maybe i'm starting to
think i actually like black's position
um the pony actually might try and get
the draw here just by continuing to
check the black king he's shaking his
head isn't he this is the sign this is a
sign that he's
both sideshaking
i think a draw is quite fair here to be
fair again i mean they've both had their
chances but we've seen that
she's playing for the win he's playing
for the win yeah
man magnus's head shake though was
relief he knows he's escaped the worst
yeah we've seen different types of shape
uh head shakes from him
i like that devin
we can we know what they're doing when
they're the way they shake their head
down
too many times already on the tour but i
love the way jan's going for it he could
have taken the draw in a position that
seems to me very dangerous for white
he's unpinned his rook the white king
temporarily safe so the white rook is
finally free to roam again and black's
queen lines herself up with a black
bishop keeping an eye on that remaining
white pawn just in case the white rook
gets careless and moves away i i must
admit i'm a little bit concerned for
napolmyashi's position because i think
jan might have
might be taking it too far
i mean it's concerning for both
positions
i mean it really is i mean he's the one
who's playing for the win and of course
does fortune favor the brave we said
this is what you should do to when
you're playing chess you should always
try to play for the win but you know it
is magnus and um sometimes you have to
think i've missed my chance let's take
the draw and get on with the next game
um i just have a feeling both players
have stopped caring about the result
they're both just focused on the process
trying to find tricks for trying to keep
the game going as long as possible i
mean if white if if yang can get his
rook into the game with a with a timely
check then he does have to and he's he's
going for it so he's trying to you know
weave a net around the black king it's
still it again seems like
black's king is actually weaker you know
now that the rook's in play
i think things are slightly more in
white's favor than they were a few moves
ago
partly because black is a bit stuck the
black bishop can't move without allowing
any deadly checks from the white queen
the black queen can't move without any
allowing any checks so the pawn has to
push but this pawn if it doesn't come
through and become a new queen itself
then it might just drop off the board so
okay a check to the black king you have
to be really careful where you go with
the king now only two safe squares
it's impossible for humans to work out
this position i mean the computer is
very good with queens and queen checks
but for a human to to find the right
check it's really really hard uh both
these guys fantastic with their queens
though aren't they the best two well
they're fantastic with every piece but
they're the queens especially they're
two of the best players in the world um
magnus said this in his fuchsia he said
napolita is the best in the world when
it's queens and heavy pieces queens and
rooks on the board is that
i i was thinking that there was some
nice tricks king went to the dark square
root g4 would have won uh i think but
okay i mean even here
this this king is really walking
walking dangerously at the moment yeah
more checks yeah white's king went on an
adventure earlier then it kind of got
scared and ran away now black's king is
the one yeah going walkabouts is that
black king going to run back to safety
or is it going to continue its journey
is going forward stepping forward again
wow
the advantage that jan's got here is
he's always got the draw because um
there's no way that black king can light
from the hyphen check so yang can always
take a perpetual check but can he do
better and the only way he's going to do
better is to get that rook again
into into a better position somehow yeah
um
he has to do it with tempo right because
that black horn is so so advanced you
know it's two squares away from queening
i i wouldn't blame uh napoli for just
bailing out repeating moves
at some point he's got to surely he
can't he can't keep rolling the dice um
if the black king goes back now that
will be the second time we've seen this
position but can magnus play for the win
can can magnus just kind of zigzag his
king towards the white king and uh kind
of bring his king the other way and then
use the black pawn as shelter from the
tracks he's trying to play for the win
you can get mated here though i mean you
go queen b1 queen f1 queen f2 check me
yeah maybe we can show that dave that's
like this if you try and bring your
queen around the other way you actually
get chipmated
and uh
i mean
this is
you know you okay let's run away oh no
hello check mate all of a sudden so it's
the death yeah
that is the kiss of death yeah yeah
magnus has to be super careful but he is
the one playing for the win he could
have taken the draw by just putting the
black king back retreating it but no
he's coming in now also there are ideas
such as bringing the rook across sliding
it back with checkmate
this looks super scary i think if the
rook comes across black has to maybe
even sacrifice the queen and yeah or you
could capture here white's queen will
take and are these pawns quick enough i
think they are but
this one still probably just a boring
draw i mean if it ends in a boring
drawing are we going to see it we're
going to see it the current position
checkmate is threatened white's coming
back to trap the black king i think
black has to give up the queen you have
to do this or you have to give a check
would he find it this time david he will
find it this time he's always found it
every other time i mean he has to find
it's the only move he only moves so you
have to i mean you have to find his move
otherwise you resign yeah if the queen
checks for example white's rook will
come back and block and actually still
check mating ideas 30 seconds 30 seconds
to go back to the players will he find
this move queen takes pawn on this
square this would save the game 22 is
going quick
ticking down does he look nervous no the
magnus looks super calm i think he's
spotted that he can bail out with a draw
queen takes pawn he's looking for better
but he has to go play he can't play
football maybe he cannot maybe he can
try to
okay he's
i mean i guess this is just the drawer
isn't it of course he's still playing
for more actually magnus yeah i mean
he's kingy too isn't it okay he's still
trying to win this position so the
reason we think it will be a draw is
because one of the black pawns will cost
white his rook
and uh one of the other black pawns will
just drop off the board so white's rook
does have time to go and win both of the
black pawns but will have to give itself
up in the process especially that black
d-pawn is two squares away from
promoting the only way to stop it is to
give up your rook this this to me is
like one of the games not just of uh um
the knockout stage a bit of the
tournament it's been so it's been so up
and down i mean it might not be the best
game according to computer but for drama
it's been great because they've both
missed wins they've both been attacking
they've both turned down draws it's got
everything uh that you'd want in a game
this is going to look good on the
fighting chess index i was about to say
the same card their fighting index
scores are going to go through the roof
after this game and uh yeah i mean fair
play to both players now the game will i
think finally reach its conclusion we
saw a couple of checks from white but no
progress to be made black's pawn just
simply too strong but he has to keep
checking otherwise black will win and uh
here we go we're about to see
the second draw of the final
dramatic draw it's been i bet you they
both shake their head right you know
when when they when they had the draw
they i bet you they both like oh no
that's it yeah
yeah
will magnus shake his head give us a
head shake magnus
probably no
yawn is definitely